hello and welcome to the second part in
native language the IPA to learn about
pronunciation and language like vowels
when we talk about consonants in the
context of phonetics in the IPA we don't
tend to say the letter B or the
consonant B instead we distinguish
features the building blocks that make
up consonants for starters we'll
consider 3 basic features of consonants
first where in your mouth do you make
this consonant sound
in other words where's the consonant
sound coming from in your mouth the
linguistic term for that is place of
articulation you articulate the sound
somewhere so that's the place of
articulation there are multiple places
of articulation that help us distinguish
where the sound is coming from if it
involves both of your lips like the
sound P that's going to be a bilabial
sound by labial meaning both lips if it
involves your tongue against your upper
teeth that's going to be a dental sound
like if you place your tongue
against the back of the gum Ridge above
your upper teeth that's an alveolar
sound like s if you run your tongue up
from your gum Ridge further back towards
your palate you can make a post alveolar
sound like tion and then eventually
you'll get to your palate the roof of
your mouth that produces a palatal sound
like yeah further back in your mouth you
have your vellum that produces a velar
sound like k inside your throat you have
a glottis and that produces a glottal
sound like the catch in your throat in a
we've skipped some places of
articulation but that's a good start
that covers where you pronounce sounds
but what about how you pronounce them
that's called the manner of articulation
if you force air up through your nose
that's a nasal sound so you can put your
tongue against your gum ray
but force the air up through your nose
which produces the sound n you could
momentarily stop the airflow to make a
stop or a closed if so the sound K is a
velar sound it involves the back of your
mouth that's its place of articulation
and the stopping of air which makes it
oppose 'iv that's its manner of
articulation another type of sound is a
fricative from latin meaning to rub that
involves the kind of continuous
restricted hissing airflow between your
tongue and wherever you're producing the
sound or in the case of the bilabial
fricative between your two lips so if
you close your lips and you produce a
fricative sound by letting the air hiss
through you get a Japanese F sound
if you move your tongue up to your
alveolar Ridge where you made that nasal
sound n and instead let the air continue
to pass through your tongue and gum
Ridge you get the sound
another type or manner of articulation
is the approximate which includes the
glides year and war in English so there
are more manners of articulation just
like there were more places of
articulation
the third feature to distinguish here is
voicing which involves letting the vocal
chords in your voice box vibrate
together opening and closing them really
fast when you do that you actually
produce a voiced sound instead of a
voiceless sound vowels are typically all
voiced that's where they get their name
from in fact but consonants can be
voiceless the classic test to tell a
difference between voiced sounds and
voiceless sounds is to put your fingers
against your throat you'll feel that
your throat vibrates whenever you say
voiced sound and it doesn't whenever you
say a voiceless sound there are sounds
that have the same place of articulation
and manner of articulation but differ in
voicing only for instance s and z are
pronounced the same way at the same
place in your mouth but is voiceless and
is voiced
you can't see it but my throat's
vibrating you can try it for yourself
just as with vowels we can lay
consonants out on a chart by their
component features this time on the
y-axis will take manner of articulation
on the x-axis will take place of
articulation and the z axis will be
voiced voiceless pairs since this is
two-dimensional we'll write that as
voiceless sound , voiced sound
for instance s comma Z in the same place
and manner of articulation I'll read
some basic consonant sounds off to you
in this chart so you can hear them and
associate them with the individual IPA
symbols hmm-hmm-hmm but the
good shhh
are ye